[Music]
hi my name is Hilda and I'm here to tell
the story of how I built and shipped
expanded gender options at Pinterest
some things I'm going to cover are why
do expanded gender options in product
matter how we design the future and
measured its effectiveness and what I
learned so gender forms
whenever I'm signing up for a new app or
service and I come across those
not-so-fun radio buttons that only have
male or female I feel a lot of feelings
most of them are not good ones and I
have a lot of thoughts like why why are
you asking me for this information there
are a lot of reasons why tenders tend to
get baked into product there may be your
medical reasons there might be legal or
compliance reasons but mostly its
demographics or marketing like ad
targeting yay ad anyway I'm not saying
that these are good reasons I'm just
saying that this is kind of why it
happened when I first signed up for
Pinterest way before I started working
there I noticed those fun you know radio
buttons that reinforce the gender binary
and aside little did I know that I would
soon be in a position to change that
but how did I get there software
engineering is not my first career I
have a degree in gender studies and then
I spent about five years working in
human resources which was kind of fun in
some ways but then I got tired of
performing emotional labor on behalf of
corporations so I quit my job learn to
code and got my very first engineering
job at Pinterest I was [ __ ] terrified I
had no idea what I was doing and was
basically convinced that I would be
fired at any moment somehow I managed to
work through all that pain confusion
fear and terror and learned a bunch of
stuff and now it's been three years and
I haven't been fired yet so yeh anyway
after I first got hired about a year
past and then I started to feel more
confident not just that my technical
skills but my interpersonal
understanding of the you know politics
that were going on around and above me
and how people actually work together to
build and ship products being the kind
of stirring it up sort of person that I
am I started some conversations about
the gender thing
I wouldn't say those conversations were
great but neither were they awful people
were like yeah I mean this isn't going
to move our core metrics we should just
focus on things that are now don't get
me wrong I was never under the
impression that expanded gender options
are going to move core metrics that's
not the point it's a kind of feature you
build because it's the right thing to do
if you want your product to be inclusive
of everybody so I realized that it was
up to me if I wanted this feature to
exist I was going to have to make it
happen and I was pretty sure I could
figure it out also I realized that I
could leverage lack of code ownership
which was actually a big problem across
the whole organization I didn't have to
ask for permission because no one no one
owned that code I could just build it
here's kind of a rundown of the backend
changes that I made
so before I even started working at
Pinterest we had this enum that
represents a user's gender the reason
that unspecified gender predated me
because someone had run an AV experiment
and discovered that if you don't force
people to put in their gender you get
more signups surprise surprise so what I
did I added an optional string to the
user struct to represent a user's custom
gender value it is my firm belief that
gender should be represented by a string
not a binary value so that way people
can put in whatever they want including
emoji what's the plural of emoji is it
emojis emoji anyway emoji are getting
more and more important because as
technology becomes more ubiquitous so
does text-based communication and emoji
are a great way of adding subtext to
text making emoji and how all of Unicode
representative of the full spectrum of
human diversity that exists is a little
outside the scope of my talk today but I
will say that these the emoji I'm
showing on screen don't officially exist
yet although I hope they do soon we are
getting a non binary emoji though in the
2017 spec which is pretty rad anyway
let's talk about internationalization
and localization and how they relate to
gender people use these terms
interchangeably but they're not exactly
the same localization is the process of
adapting your product the text the
design to work in one specific market so
this picture here is from the movie
inside out in it the protagonist Riley
she's a little girl and she
hates broccoli except for in Japan where
she hates green peppers green peppers
are a vegetable that are more hated by
children in Japan than broccoli
since inside out is a movie about
feelings and empathy it was important to
get little details right so the movie
would work cross-culturally so
internationalisation is the more general
use case like let's say you you kept
having this vegetable problem and you
decided to build like a vegetable
injector and you know ship it so that
you could show users a different
vegetable based on where they are in the
world that would be an example of
internationalization it's kind of like
the tools and frameworks that enable you
to localize in multiple languages a base
use case for localization okay you have
an english string and it represents some
user-facing copy this string has a
placeholder value in it that represents
the users username at runtime we look up
the user's language settings and then
replace the string with the string in
their language and then also replace a
placeholder value so if I'm a German
user and my name is tilde hello user
name becomes hallo tilde how does this
why does this matter for expanded gender
options well I'm not a linguist so bear
with me but there's this concept of
grammatical gender that about a quarter
of the world's languages have
grammatically gendered languages have
two nouns have genders and you have to
match the other parts of speech in the
sentence like verbs and so forth with a
noun
English does not it's not grammatically
gendered but it does have still has
gender baked into it in all kinds of
little places like third-person pronouns
and titles so when I first decided to
build expanded gen dachshunds for
Pinterest I I wanted to allow users to
supply their preferred pronoun to
it's more inclusive to not only allow
people to say what their gender is but
to specify how they would like to be
referred to unfortunately that didn't
really work out because the localization
provider that we were using didn't
handle gender in placeholder strings so
we kind of had to work around that on
the plus side the translation provider
not using gendered placeholder strings
meant that all of our user facing copy
was already gender neutral as it refers
to users the writing team hates it
because you end up with some kind of
awkwardly worded sentences where you're
avoiding pronouns but at the same time
it I didn't have to do any extra work oh
this is awkward thank you I didn't have
to do any extra work to make our text
work for users who don't identify as
male or female and who cares what the
writing team thinks that's pretty cool
so if you're not like Pinterest and
you're not like locked into a contract
with a certain localization provider you
have options I found a bunch of software
packages that support localization of
gender and placeholder strings
out-of-the-box caveat I have not used
any of these personally so I if you have
I would love to know what your
experience is like come find me after
the talk or tweet at me or something man
let's talk can we talk about pronouns
for a second pronouns are complicated I
wanted to shout out to ge'ez comp for
having the little preferred gender
pronoun buttons that makes my heart warm
I hope every conference that's doing
that
anyway a lot of a lot of people who
don't identify as male or female use
Bey's their preferred gender pronoun but
there are so many pronouns out there the
website pronoun island is trying to list
all the pronouns and their different
conjugations and stuff which i think is
amazing it does present kind of a
quadrant II for localization though if
it's like how to use how these concepts
translate cross-culturally and cross
languages some languages don't have
gendered pronouns at all some languages
like Farsi have pronouns for different
if an object is Animas inanimate for
example so since this is all really
complicated make sure that your copy
writers and translators are working with
linguists to understand best practices
for gender-neutral writing in that
language
alright so talked about the back end
talked about localization stuff then I
did the front end and the earth or the
middle where an API changes blah blah
blah and then I made the front end
changes the first thing I did was put
user gender on the settings page
politically speaking it's pretty easy to
put user gender on the settings page
it's like the junk drawer of any
application and no one gives a [ __ ]
funny thing happened after I did this
though people even though the
conversation I started earlier it's been
a little lukewarm people came out of the
woodwork to to support me and they're
like oh this is so cool what can I do to
help I was like well I was like wow it
sure would be great if we supported this
feature on iOS and Android as well so I
was able to kind of shoulder taps and
people to make that happen
it didn't quite solve the original
problem though users still had to put in
their genders when they signed up for
Pinterest and I wanted to fix that
unlike the settings page the signup form
is Oh No
unlike the settings page the signup form
is very political and people really care
about every pixel on that page and it
impacts top line metrics so I knew that
we would need to take a more data-driven
approach here are a few design
iterations we went through on the way to
shipping expanded gender options on
planets the first thing I tried is
putting a simple radio button in when a
user checks the radio button another
text box pops up where they can put in
their custom gender value the problem
with this is the signup code was reused
in many places which is a good thing
right don't repeat yourself but one of
those places was narrow little any
little modal and when you
internationalize text or when text is
localized into longer languages such as
French or German you need to account for
about 30 percent more room for that text
so the text didn't fit in French and
German in the skinny modal I could have
just made it wider but I didn't want my
didn't want this feature coupled with a
certain specific design I wanted it to
be more robust because I knew I wouldn't
have a lot of time to maintain it I
asked the design friend for feedback or
suggestions this is what he came up with
there are a couple of problems with this
number one there is no universal signal
that are no universal symbol that
represents all users who don't identify
as male or female except maybe the
principal
number two a lot of people just
straight-up can't remember which symbol
means male and which symbol means female
and number three this was meant to get
us around the localization or the the
text length problem but these symbols
don't work all that well cross
culturally not so fun fact but symbols
and homosexuality are illegal in Russia
and a symbol for non-binary people could
fall into that category
so really this just wasn't going to fly
with anybody alright fine I'll just do
the hacky thing and make them narrow
modal little wider and move on with my
life but nope as blunt the person who
was responsible for the metrics of the
signup forms strongly felt like this was
going to cause problems he was really
worried that Pinterest main demographic
of conservative Midwestern moms would
object for a little while the project
stalled and thus frustrated I didn't
know what to do and then in the way of
tech companies there was a reorg
suddenly I was reporting to this person
who had blocked me before so my first
one-on-one with him I said I'm down I
was like look if you want me to trust
you and be on your team
then you need to get me some face time
with a designer who can help me get this
form to meet your arbitrary standards
and you know what he came through for me
it's a little bit of a tricky design
problem right like how do you how do you
make a feature visible for the small
minority of users who really care about
it but not so visible as the majority
who might not understand or be upset
won't notice it and get too soft this is
what we came up with there's a little
info icon when you
morover we show a tool tip on the tool
tip we explain why we want this
information which is kind of important
and then allow you to put in your custom
gender string after user click Save we
replace male or female with the text
that they typed in so we rolled this out
as an a/b experiment
unfortunately sign up for down about 1%
wobb wobb back to the drawing board
hypothesize that maybe users were
unintentionally triggering the hover
interaction and getting confused so I
said let's make this a click interaction
when we tried it with a click
interaction signup for flat so we
shipped it yay thank you finally we also
I measured that people were actually
using the custom gender part because if
signups were flat but if no one's
actually using it then what's the point
right but then we took things even a
step further I was approached by a
designer on the mobile team and she's
like hey I'm just I'm redoing the whole
mobile signup flow and why is custom
gender on web so hidden why can't we
just put it in there with the other
options and I was like you are not going
to get any argument from me about that
this was wrapped in an a/b experiment
too of course
it's not exactly an apples to apples
comparison because the new signup flow
is visually very different but the
metrics are better for it so that's what
we went with
of course quantitative metrics never
tell the whole story so we did
qualitative user research as well
sentiment towards cuts and gender
options in this research is positive
people said things like custom gender is
an awesome idea for our progressive
social
we got some love on social media as well
the whole the whole process got me
thinking like why why is this teacher so
important to me why do I care so much so
on this slide of the movie which some of
you have clearly seen called
but I'm a cheerleader in this movie
Megan the main character has a
realization but not everybody struggles
with same-sex attraction she's different
she's a lesbian
building this feature I realized not
everybody has feels about having to put
their gender into a box I do I'm
different I'm not binary what does this
mean for me still figuring that out tbh
so just to recap building this feature
taught me that you can leverage the
chaos that will inevitably be present in
your organization to advance your social
justice warrior agenda
after I got the ball rolling people came
out of the woodwork to help me and
finally the process of writing software
building stuff getting it right getting
it wrong can teach you about yourself
in ways that you might not expect thank
you